and a new world my whole life was based
on lie
can't go back to the way things were a
real man doesn't avoid hard things
he faces but scarcity
you dress and buckle up fool yeah
take off the cloud Chase take off the
Wi-Fi we need to talk the house just
isn't the same when Will's not home it's
a real world outside what's going on
will just want to take care of myself
let me sing the songs I made where'd
this money come from there's a couple
street ball games no big deal you
stepping away
okay now I'm worried
I did what I did for Will's sake what's
filling with his back baby but he's
referring back to his old ways let's go
there's this big time Scout and he
talked a lot of dudes get to the pose
that fancy Bel Air Team got you and your
game so if you can't work with me sky's
the limit for caught a meal hell if I
know we need to talk about our
partnership you're a boss I'm just
trying to bring it out if you don't
accept the tone she's gonna keep on
walking all over you
I was trying to be someone different the
BSU the protests all people see are my
mistakes yeah forever let anyone try to
change you
can't believe you're going back so soon
well baby you know I can't sit still for
too long when is it my time to feel
valued
I wish to create a legacy where we are
represented
I think it's time you take the gloves
off babe right Carlton
you can't be friends anymore
we can't do this to you fight for your
principles I have anxiety trying to fit
into this goddamn Bella bubble we all
need to step up you got a new Jeffrey
Wisdom
foreign
[Music]